[Musik]
kuba ein land zwischen stillstand und
erneuerung nach 60 jahren sozialismus
drängt es junge menschen neues
auszuprobieren
[Musik]
du brauchst du etwas geld ein paar leute
die dich unterstützen ein bisschen glück
und eier
sie setzen auf eigeninitiative wo lange
alles über den start lief die politik
hier ist eine schweinerei das ist die
wahrheit hier wird absolut nicht gelöst
[Musik]
wo die einen gefrustet sind sehen die
anderen neue möglichkeiten
platz für eine neue generation dann kann
hier endlich was passieren
wir fahren seit 60 jahren die gleiche
linie venro leto kocht dann ist immer
auch ein bisschen improvisation im spiel
denn an irgendwelchen zutaten fehlt es
eigentlich immer im sozialistischen kuba
manchmal sogar an den unglaublichsten
dinge zucker wie kann es sein dass in
einem land wie kuba der zucker fehlt
[Musik]
manchmal findet er einen ersatz an
anderen tagen ändert er kurzerhand das
menü in seinem restaurant mangel gehört
zur realität in kuba jahrzehntelange
misswirtschaft hat dazu geführt dass das
land 80 prozent seiner lebensmittel
importieren muss
das führt oft zu engpässen
kubaner sind das gewöhnt aber touristen
haben andere erwartungen und raul ito
weiß dass statt die knappheit zu
verbergen will er lieber verständnis
wecken dafür dass kuba eben nicht nur
alte autos bunte fassaden und schöne
musik bedeutet der erwartung der kunden
ist das alles was auf der karte steht
auch verfügbar ist keiner hört gerne
dass es etwas nicht gibt deshalb rede
ich mit den gästen
ich versuche ihnen zu erklären dass es
nicht so wichtig ist
improvisieren steckt kubanern praktisch
in den genen
aber viele haben den ewigen mangel auch
satt immer mehr verlassen das land leto
will lieber teil der lösung sein
die leute glauben irgendwie dass es
ihnen anderswo besser gehen wird deshalb
gehen sie das tut kuba wie es ist ein
soziales problem mit meiner arbeit hier
versuche ich zu zeigen dass es möglich
ist in kuba zu arbeiten sich ein leben
aufzubauen und so glücklich zu sein wie
es eben geht
während raul ito und nach vorne blickt
ist draußen nicht die zukunft sondern
die vergangenheit angesagt kuba
vermarktet nostalgie und zieht damit
touristen an
für besucher von außen hat der
stillstand etwas romantisches doch
selbst das zu bewahren ist harte arbeit
die plaza vieja ein koloniales
schmuckstück die alten gebäude hier
wurden schritt für schritt restauriert
irgendwann soll ganz havanna wieder so
aussehen eine riesenaufgabe architektin
norma ist stolz auf das was sie schon
erreicht haben
nach so vielen jahren harter arbeit auf
diesem platz zu stehen der wie eine
zusammenfassung unserer arbeit ist toll
das ist eine große genugtuung und
gleichzeitig eine verpflichtung weiter
zu arbeiten wenn man auf diesen platz
tritt dann fühlt man das ist havanna ein
großteil der bauwerke havannas stammt
aus kolonialzeiten sie rocken seit
jahren vor sich hin jetzt drängt die
zeit
priorität bei der restaurierung haben
gebäude des öffentlichen interesses für
die meisten wohnhäuser bedeutet dass
hinten anstellen
immer häufiger kommt jede hilfe zu spät
nach starken regenfällen sacken
regelmäßig gebäude in sich zusammen
die bewohner der altstadt sind solche
anblicke gewohnt sie nehmen es gelassen
havanna ist 500 jahre alt es kann nicht
mehr
das haus war sogar noch bewohnt als es
in sich zusammenfiel
die bewohner hatten glück es ist
niemandem etwas passiert aber wieso lebt
überhaupt noch jemand in solchen
bruchbuden wohnraum in havanna ist knapp
das wird einem so richtig bewusst wenn
man einen blick hinter die historischen
fassaden wirft ein typisches wohnhaus im
hinterhof leben 28 familien es ist eng
sie hausen in anbauten und
zwischengeschossen marke eigenbau wir
treffen s3 das leben hier ist mühsam
wir sind nicht an das wassernetz
angeschlossen wir müssen unser wasser in
eimern hier her schleppen in der
altstadt haben sie alles schön repariert
aber bis hierher sind sie noch nicht
gekommen ist er träumt von einer eigenen
wasserleitung einen tank hat sie schon
vor der tür
jetzt fehlen ihr noch ein paar rohre ich
muss einige teile kaufen jedes davon
kostet 10 dollar
mit meiner arbeit in der krankenhaus
kantine verdiene ich 20 dollar im monat
da kann ich nur wenig sparen ich muss ja
auch was essen wie es trainer haben im
sozialistischen kuba 85 prozent der
bevölkerung einen staatlichen job das
durchschnittseinkommen liegt zwischen 30
und 40 dollar im monat
das reicht kaum zum leben auch wenn es
zuschüsse zur grundversorgung gibt und
sie fast keine miete zahlen müssen
nebenan wäscht pantera alte eisbecher
aus um sich zu seinem staatlichen gehalt
etwas dazu zu verdienen
alles was wir brauchen müssen wir uns
irgendwie zusammen suchen sonst sterben
wir so langsam vor uns hin
im gerede der leute ist immer alles toll
aber das stimmt nicht
es ist hart seine frau beatrice hat
ihren staatlichen job ganz aufgegeben
sie hat die nase voll vom alltäglichen
kampf
ich bin kubanerin bin hier geboren und
aufgewachsen aber die situation hier
passt mir nicht und vielen anderen auch
nicht
keiner will mehr für die regierung
arbeiten weil das was man dafür bekommt
ein witz ist
du gibst einmal auf den markt und es
bleibt nichts übrig daran dass sich
etwas ändert glaubt beatrice nicht mehr
einer muss ja mal die wahrheit sagen die
politik hier das ist eine
riesenschweinerei
sie löst absolut nichts häuser stürzten
ein und nichts passiert gestern konnte
man hier nicht den gang entlang gehen
weil alles voller scheiße war
was glaubst du warum alle das land
verlassen weil das hier so nicht
weitergeht
tausende kubaner beantragen jahr für
jahr asyl in den usa aber immer mehr
junge leute wählen einen anderen weg
verbesserung zu hause wie kamille und
lucia
sie haben einen podcast gestartet ich
glaube die aufgabe von uns jungen
kubanern ist die hoffnung nicht
aufzugeben alles zu tun was wir können
damit es irgendwann einmal spürbare
radikale veränderung gibt denn eines ist
klar alle wollen veränderungen
meine ganze familie ist in den usa aber
mein platz ist hier
ich will hier etwas aufbauen und ein
podcast ist für mich eine art des
ausbaus
es ist mein kleiner beitrag zum
öffentlichen diskurs
sie sind noch ganz am anfang
gerade nehmen sie die fünfte folge auf
sie wollen diskutieren unterschiedliche
meinungen präsentieren
die ideen dafür holen sie sich aus den
sozialen medien allein das ist eine
kleine revolution
ich bin in den 90er jahren aufgewachsen
damals kam man kaum an informationen aus
der außenwelt wir hatten nur die
staatlichen medien
das hat sich geändert heute haben die
menschen zugang zum internet sehen
andere realitäten die welt entwickelt
sich mit atemberaubender geschwindigkeit
und wir zuckeln hinterher
das schränkt uns ein die leute wollen
ausbrechen aus der trägheit aus dem
vorgegebenen pfad wollen neues aus
kuba war eines der letzten länder der
welt wo normale menschen zugang zum
internet bekamen erst seit 2005 10 ist
das möglich und camilo und lucia nutzen
das voll aus vor allem twitter finden
sie gut
es bietet möglichkeiten zum dialog unser
präsident eröffnete einen twitter
account und wies seine minister an das
auch zu tun damit man direkt mit der
regierung kommunizieren kann
vorher war das praktisch unmöglich und
plötzlich konntest du über twitter eine
minister schreiben und den präsidenten
deine gedanken mitteilen
ein parteien staat cooper in dem kritik
unerwünscht ist und dissidenten
unterdrückt werden wäre das eine
radikale veränderung wie ernst meint es
die regierung denn wirklich gemischt
manche minister blockieren kubaner der
kommunikationsminister hat mich zum
beispiel geblockt dennoch es sind
möglichkeiten zum dialog entstanden und
die funktionieren bekommen feedback
darüber was das volk denkt das land
könnte sich aus einem käfig einem
gefängnis in etwas verwandeln wo sich
alle frei fühlen erste online proteste
gibt es auf jeden fall schon unter
hashtag lacroix challenge husten user
bilder von endlosen warteschlange denn
die gibt es hier überall und für alles
mögliche für benzin an der
bushaltestelle sogar für seife es gibt
zweifel
tagelang gab es gar keine jetzt müssen
wir uns dafür anstellen
wir haben die schlange gesehen sind
sofort umgedreht und haben uns
angestellt
der mangel ist nicht nur hausgemacht die
schwierigkeiten im verbündeten venezuela
und das us handelsembargo erschweren die
situation vor einigen jahren begann
präsident obama eine politik der öffnung
mit dem ehemaligen erzfeind damals
herrschte aufbruchstimmung endlich
schien es vorwärts zu gehen
donald trump macht jetzt die öffnung
schritt für schritt wieder rückgängig
bei obama alle und jetzt warum hat raul
ito dann trotzdem gerade jetzt ein
restaurant eröffnet ich finde die
tramper besser während der obama zeit
waren alle verrückt es war wie eine
kollektive pubertät dass diese blase
irgendwann platzt war klar ich sage
nicht dass ich krebs politik gut finde
aber damals ging alles viel zu schnell
sein rat nichts überstürzen
das ist wohl genau das richtige motto
für alle die auf veränderung in kuba
hoffen die alten strukturen sitzen tief
und wer neues aufbauen will braucht
einen langen atem
[Musik]